uh you're a student of history fan of
dan carlin's hardcore history podcast
yeah that's great greatest podcast ever
yeah i think it is actually
i i it does it almost doesn't really
count as a podcast yeah it's like it's
it's more like a audiobook yeah so you
were on the podcast with dan i just had
to chat with him about it
he said you guys want military and all
that kind of stuff uh yeah it's
literally uh it was basically um
uh i think it should be titled engineer
wars uh essentially like like when
there's a rapid change in the rate of
technology then uh
engineering plays a pivotal role in in
victory in battle
um
do you how far in back in history did
you go did you go world war ii
uh it was mostly
well it was supposed to be a deep dive
on fighters and bomber
uh technology in world war ii um but
that ended up being more wide-ranging
than that um
because i just went down the total rat
hall of like
studying all of the fighters and bombers
world war ii and like the constant rock
paper scissors game that like you know
uh one country would make this plane
then make a plane to beat that and
that's trying to make plane to beat that
and then
and really what matters like the pace of
innovation um and also access to high
quality uh
fuel and uh raw materials so like
germany had like some amazing designs
but they couldn't make them uh because
they couldn't get their raw materials
and uh
they they had a real problem with the
oil and and
uh fuel basically the fuel quality was
extremely uh variable so the design
wasn't the bottleneck it was uh yeah
like the the u.s had kick-ass fuel uh
that was like very
consistent like the problem if you make
a very high performance aircraft engine
um in order to make high performance you
have to um
the the
the
the fuel the aviation gas uh
has to be a consistent mixture and uh
uh it has to have a high high octane um
like high octane is the most important
thing but also can't have like
impurities and stuff uh because you'll
fall up the engine
and and german just never had good
access oil like they tried to get it by
invading the caucasus
um but that didn't work too well
that never works well i broke up with
him
nice to meet you
so they always was germany was always
struggling with with basically
shitty oil um and then they could not uh
they couldn't count on up on high
quality fuel for their aircraft so then
they had to add all they have all these
additives and and stuff
uh so um
uh whereas the us had awesome fuel um
and that provided that to britain as
well um so
that allowed the british and the
americans to design aircraft engines
that were uh super high performance
better than anything else in the world
germany could could design the engines
they just didn't have the fuel and then
also the right like the the
uh the quality of the aluminum allies
they were getting was also not that
great and so yeah did you is this like
uh you talked about all this with dan
yep awesome
you